I want to address this question that came in here, curious of why you think the MX clinic
is unnecessary is a lump back to be easier, cheaper, better, P.S. the surgeon hasn't called
me yet.
Yes, I don't think that going to the Mexico clinic is going to be a replacement for the
lump back to me or the mastectomy.
I just don't think that that's going to happen.
I don't think going to the Mexico clinic is going to make this shrink and disappear down
to zero.
Anything's possible, God can do anything, but I don't think that will it.
I know you're interested in trying to save your notes.
It's if you have the ability to go down there and do it, and your surgeon still hasn't even
called you yet, and you can get down there and do this and try this and see if you can get
even more shrinkage by all means go for it, I'm all for 100%.
All right, this question I'm interested in running a short rife program prior to my nightly
cancer program.
How do I set up the system before going to bed so that it will run two sessions in sequence
without having to wake up to launch the second program?
This is what is called program stacking.
So I have a video on the rife section about stacking programs.
I'll look and make sure, but Mike in his true rife videos has a video on stacking programs.
I don't do that.
So I can't remember off the top of my head how to do that, but it's really a simple function
how to pick a program and then you pick another program and there's some things that you
do on the rife thing on the rife program and you stack it and you hit run and it'll play
the first program and it'll play the second program and that's it's very simple.
I think it's about a four minute video on how to stack programs.
I'll find it and I'll put it up on the member site if it's not there already called stacking